let's go
okay
good evening members and officers
welcome to the extraordinary cabinet
meeting
um
sorry a bit frog in the throat this
evening
welcome and fire alarm procedures
excuse me if the fire alarm is activated
vacate the offices via the stairs please
do not use the lifts assembling hawley
square on the green officers will assist
you in advise when it is deemed safe to
return to the chamber
please switch off or turn to silent your
mobile phones and do not make or receive
calls whilst the meeting is in progress
please note this meeting is being live
stream for members of
of the public
the meeting will also be recorded and
will subsequently be broadcast on the
internet
i don't believe anyone wishes to film
the meeting
i have um no members at the moment
indicating if they wish to speak on any
of the items there's
councillor yates which item council yet
um councillor uh a gender item four
please
okay
thank you i have apologies for
councillor david saunders
and councillor pugh i believe he's
attending he might just be a smidge lake
but i will give apologies if he doesn't
show
does anyone have any interest to declare
in the items of business for the agenda
this evening
so i'll move straight on to item three
which is the birchington neighborhood
plan
regulation 16 consultation formal
response from thanet district council
and this is for me to introduce
a draft neighbourhood plan is being
prepared for birchington by the
neighborhood plan group and parish
council
as part of its statutory role in this
process the council is currently running
a public consultation known as
regulation 16 on the birchington
neighbourhood plan which finishes on
thursday the 24th of february
this is the last chance for comments to
be made on the draft plan
before it is examined by an independent
examiner
it's very clear that a large
sorry a large amount of time
thought and care has gone into the
preparation of this document it is well
set out easy to read and understand and
attractive with its photos maps and
other images
the quality of this draft neighborhood
plan shows the dedication and enthusiasm
of all those involved
the draft neighborhood plan is generally
to be supported however there are some
areas of concern and they are set out in
paragraph 1.11 of the report
the main issue of the concern relates to
the proposed green wedge areas
the existing green wedges have been long
established and protected by local plan
policies since 1980s
the proposed green wedges would
undermine the local plan policy as they
do not conform with the aims of the
local plan policy sp 25
safeguarding the identity of thanet's
settlements
this relates to the land marked 12 27 28
and 29 on the green and open space map
on page 41 of the draft neighborhood
plan
the areas marks 7 and 10 are covered by
the local plan green wedge designation
it should be noted that the areas of
countryside to which this relates are no
are already protected by virtue of
general countryside policies
with the urban boundary drawn tightly
around birchington including the
strategic site allocated in the local
plan
not having a green wedge policy for
those areas does not mean that they are
areas are suitable for new development
more detailed comments on these points
are set out in annex 1 to the report
once all the comments have been received
the x
examination into the draft plan will be
undertaken by the independent examiner
the examiner will consider all the
comments made in relation to the draft
neighborhood plan and make
recommendations as to any changes they
consider are needed to meet government
guidance
we are currently working with
birchington parish council to appoint
the examiner and hope to complete that
soon
i move this recommendation
do i have a seconder councillor
bayford no one is asked to speak under
20.1 but do cabinet have any comment
so are we approving this
cabinet we are
agreed
so item four climate emergency
cag recommendations to introduce
councillor bob baford
yeah thanks cher
um kent county council has finalized the
kent and midway energy and low emissions
strategy which lays out the route to
create a low emission county and reach
net zero by 2050 for the whole of kent
the strategy has been approved by all
the relevant committees and kent leaders
in 2020 this is an opportunity to
endorse their strategy and also provide
support to each net to reach net zero in
the district within our powers and
resources bringing us in line with the
government's legally binding pledge to
make the uk net zero by twenty fifty
we can assist with the reduction in
emissions across senec through work that
we are already carrying out this
includes the action on insulating homes
by a home energy officer and the work on
sustainable transport that the air
quality and planning departments are
doing
climate change information produced by
the climate change officer and tdc comms
team are also helping residents reduce
their carbon footprint
this recommendation was taken to the
climate change cabinet advisory group on
the 13th of december 2021 and it was
approved
members are asked to consider approving
the following recommendations number one
senate district council endorses the
kent and midway energy and low emissions
strategy and number two in alignment
with this endorsement the following
paragraph is added to the council's
climate change pledge
do what is within our powers and
resources to support kcc the government
business industry and the community to
make senate as a whole net zero by 2050
so move
yep thank you leader just um
just say that as a member of the cabinet
advisory group fully support this uh
proposal um
the only comment i've got is that i wish
government would give us more powers and
resources to actually make this happen
uh quicker um but i think i think we all
of that opinion so yeah fully support
thanks
thank you councillor yates do members
agree
thank you chair and apologies for my my
lateness um i'm pleased to bring forward
this report to my cabinet colleagues for
the approval of the former effelbert
putin green site to be leased for a
skate park as part of the margate town
deal
the market town deal provides a great
opportunity for its projects to create
jobs and deliver improved well-being
this proposal in particular helps to
deliver real community activities on the
ground
dealing with the lack of social
facilities in the area that will help
deal with the gap in community cohesion
and health inequality
we know that there are challenges in
this part of margate around community
cohesion and the provision of spaces
that engage with a broad spectrum of
people the project sponsors the margate
skateboard club are experts in their
field and have been working hard to put
together a design that is suitable for
all levels of skater and have been
engaging with their community on the
designs they have also been they've also
been working with sponsors including
tracey emin who was offered 100 000
pounds for the capital project
and is also working with her contacts to
help support the skate park over the
long term
this project also enables the council to
deliver a margate skate park that we
were unable to deliver at hearthstone
park the 59 000 pounds in our capital
programmes uh wasn't enough to deliver a
decent skate park that the community was
hoping for
and there were also a number of
challenges with site
this project has remained undelivered
within our capital programme so i'm
really pleased that we are now able to
directly support the margate town deal
skatepark project
i would like to propose the following
recommendations to enable the council's
support to and deliver of the margate
skate park as part of the margate town
deal
one to give delegated authority to the
director of property to prepare and
complete the lease and all other anxiety
documents on the agreed terms in
consultation with the economic
development portfolio holder and two
excuse me to approve the capital
vehement of the full fifty nine thousand
pounds capital programme margaret's gate
park project budget to the market town
deal program the committed skate park
project for the margate for margate
within the capital programme is now due
to be delivered as part of the market
town deal and i look forward to seeing
this project being finalized and
delivered and i may even consider taking
up some skateboard lessons for the
ribbon cutting day
and i would like everyone to know that
i'm actually quite decent on skateboard
um so thank you
uh are you moving this uh councillor pew
yes apologies chair i i move this
recommendations cabinet
do i have a seconder
counselor
we have no one speaking under 20.1 but i
would like to say
that
my skateboard days are definitely over
i don't actually think they ever started
to be quite honest i'm much better on
water than i am on the concrete um
but um i'd like to thank um tracy emming
for her contribution to this um because
without that i don't think it would have
actually have happened
and so on behalf of the council i'd like
to to thank her for her kind um donation
of a hundred thousand pounds
and um very much look forward to the
first world champion coming out of the
cliftonville skateboard park
right so this has been uh moved and
seconded do members agree
that that is agreed
and um i believe that concludes the
business for this evening
yes
exactly
thank you very much members and officers
and
enjoy what's this
extended uh evening that you have now
for yourself
you